では よろしくお願いします
まああの まあこの頃あまり難しい話を聞く環境でもないと思いますけど
まあ外へ出ると まあ脳細胞は全部まああまりまあ過ぎちゃってイカれてしまいます
から まあ私も今日生き抜く頭があるかどうかも感じない程度に
まあ大変でしたけど まあ幸いこのホールの中ではまあなんとか正常ですので
まあ話は進めたいと思います
まあ当然あの 私の話はまあちょっと理解しにくい
難しいものはたくさんありますけどね
まあまあ我慢すればなんとかなるでしょうとは思います
えーと 今日のテーマはね
正しい自己診断ということで
自分で自分をチェックするための方法ということで
このテーマを聞いた途端
おそらく皆様方はまあ
日常生活において 私たちにはね
まあ自分たちの生活を性格をね
チェックして なんとかうまくまあいける方法はある
教えてくれるだろうとは思うんでしょうね
約束は守らないということは
私のまあ一つの特色ですからね
ちょっと裏切られたような気分になるかもしれません
まああの まあそういう
あの一般的ね 誰でも言ってることをね
まあここで仏教 ブッダの教えを語るときでも
そればっかり言っちゃうと
なんかもったいないと思いますね
お釈迦様がもう人間にはもう理解できないほどすごいもう智慧でいろんなものを語りましたから
皆様にもそれを聞いて理解する能力もありますからね
ですから この デパートで安売りを狙うんじゃなくてね
もうちょっと高いレベルのものを聞いておいた方がよろしいと思います
で 日常生活にはそれから役に立ちますよ
まあそれ強調しちゃうと
これバナナのたたき売りみたいになっちゃうんですね
それはしたくはないんです
こんなに安売りする必要はないんで
これはもう品質は最高で
世界一で まあこれに勝るものは存在もしないし
だからちょっと工夫してみてください
で  まず我々はある一つの言葉を学びます
この言葉はパッチャウィッカナと言うんです
パッチャウィッカナ で
パーリ経典ではまあ結構出てくる言葉で
仏教学者の方々はまあただ普通のパーリ語でしょうということで
専門用語として扱ってないんです
まあこれは普通のパーリ語やと
しかし 私がこれは普通の単語ではなくて
仏教の用語として紹介したいんです
パッチャウィッカナは反省という意味の言葉ですね
まあ軽い意味で反省ということになります
まあ英訳はたくさんありますけど
トゥドゥー カポン テンション
レビュー リアライズ コントレムプレート
リフレクト フラッシュ
レミニスクエンス リコレクト
まあいろいろあるあるは
いくらでも単語はね まあ日本語ではそれほどはないとは思いますけど
これパッチャウィッカナの普通の意味なんですね
まあ反省だと思ってください
まあ英語に訳すると まあ何かを思い出す
という意味もありますね
思い出してみなさいとということのね
しかし 仏教用語として意味は 2つあります
1 過去の出来事を観察する
2 何かを行う前に観察して決断する
なんか互い違い意味なんですね
で 普通は過去のことを思い出してください
覚えておいてくださいと
覚えているだろうよということで
パッチャウィッカナなんですね
だから 過去の出来事をあえて思い出してみること
それがこの英語で言えばリフレクトレビューですね
リコレクトと言いますね
レミニスというもの同じですね
もう過去のこと 出来事を思い出してみる
まあ子供ならね 勉強したものは宿題しながらまた思い出してみるっていうのはね
これパッチからなんですね
これ第1の意味 そんなのは簡単ですよ
それぐらいだったらね
その場合は特色は過去の出来事なんですね
思い出す場合はすべて過去なんですね
2番目の意味は 何かを行う前に観察して決断する
この場合は過去というよりも過程ですね
こうしたらどうなるのでしょうか
やった方がよろしいでしょうか
この結果に達するためには
どんなふうにやった方がよろしいでしょうかというふうに
この感が観察するんですよ
現状を だから この現状について
スタディして観察して決断するんです
これがパーリ語でパッチウェッカーというんですね
だから  1 の意味は過去を思い出すこと
2 は現実現状を観察すること
だから時間的に結構差があるんです
はい では まあまとめて反省っていうのは
私はあまり日本語はできないんだから
まあいろいろ言葉あるだろうと思いますけど
まあ一般的に使う よくみんな使う反省という言葉使ってます
反省の場合も結局は過去なんですね
何かやってから そこはまあどんなふうに行ったのか
何が良かったのか 何が悪かったのかどうかね
またそこはもう調べてみることは反省なんですね
あれあれ あれとあれとこれと間違えましたとかね
こういうところは失敗しましたとかね
こういうところはうまくいったとかね
そうやってスタディして
自分の役に立つために使う機能ですね
反省は ですから 結局は過去になりますけどね
でも私は仏教用語として皆様は難しい単語はまあどうでもいいんですから
まあ反省という言葉で理解してください
人格向上への道はパッチウェッカーは必須です
ブッダが人格向上しなさい
解脱しなさいと教えているんです
一貫して 人間のままではダメですよと
人間性を破って超越して
乗り越えて 執着捨てて解脱に達しなさいと
これはすぐできますよと
死ぬまで待つなよと 死後天国に行くという約束するならば
まあちょっとあや なんて言いますか
怪しいんだと そんな教えは
すぐ今目の前でいて ままでもう人間としてのレベルを乗り越えて
究極の幸福に達することはできますよ
解脱に達することはできますよと
それやりなさいと一貫して語っているんですね
その道に必須は反省です
パッチウェックかなです
ということで 我々日常生活で考えている反省とはちょっと違うかもしれません
かなりレベルが高いかもしれません
しかし 日常大事なのは
に 何かを行う前に実行する観察です
一般的に反省が必須です
それから パッチウェックには意味 2つです
過去を思い出すことと現状を観察すること
この 2番目がとても大事なんですね
そこで皆様には必要なのは
この 2番目の反省です
1番目はどうでもいいんです
本当は これは客観的観察だとも言えます
ですから この英語でCONSIDERという言葉
動詞がありますね 前も出しました
パッチワークかなは英訳する場合はいくつかの意味を使いますが
一般的に英訳する場合はCONSIDERという言葉は
例えば子供がお父さんにお父さんオートバイ買ってくれと
じゃあ考えてみますと言うんですね
考えてみます それはCONSIDERなんですね ICONSIDERIT OK
という意味でもないんです
買ってあげるか 買ってあげないか
半分ぐらいお金出すか
ただ どんな結論になるかということを
これからお父さんが観察するんですね
その場合で 英語で言う場合は ICONSIDER
あ 考えてみます という意味なんですね
この考えてみますということが
とても我々人生にとっては大事なことです
なぜならば それから決断する
決断してから行動する
行動が生きることなんですね
今日はパッチワークについて学びます
今日はまあなんとか約束のテーマではなくて
パッチワークについて学びます
1 過去の観察  1番目の意味
これは瞑想を実践する修行者たちが行う行為です
で 過去を思い出してくださいという修行があるんです
それがこの瞑想を修行するとやるんです
どういうことかというと
このこちら書いて書いたような気がしますけど
自分がどんなような精神状態に達していたかどうか
それは観察してみるんですね
過去を 俗世間で言っている過去を思い出すことは修行ではない
皆様も結構過去を思い出すでしょ
あれ じゃあ修行しているんですかね
あの修行じゃないんです
過去を思い出すという修行はありますけど
それと我々やっていることは結構違います
やめてしまった方が良い行為です
我々は毎日やっている
過去のことを思い出すでしょ
あれはできることならきれいさっぱりやめてください
過去がないことにしてください
私には過去がありませんと
そうすると元気に生きていられます
この過去のくだらんことを思い出すと
かなり足を引っ張られますよ
例えば過去で失敗したこと
恥をかけられたこと 思い出すたびに心が落ち込むんですよ
あの恥かきられた時のあの嫌な気持ちが再現するんです
再現して自分の心を蝕むんです
例えば失恋した場合はね
思い出してみてください
思い出すたびに 悔しくて
悲しくて いろいろ その失恋に応じて怒りに狂っちゃうかもしれません
悲しみに陥るかもしれません
だから我々は過去を思い出すということは
過去に起きたもう失敗ばっかし思い出すとは病気になる
思い出しては病気になるという
とんでもない危険な行為なんです
だから一般的には仏教の立場は過去を忘れちゃえと
過去終わっただろうと
どうでもいいでしょうにときれいさっぱり忘れるんです
忘れて元気に明るく今生きてみるんです
だから これ本当に仏教の
なんか皆さんは矛盾ではないかと勘違いするかもしれません
かなり精密なところなんです
過去を捨てちゃえっていうのは一般的なブッダの言葉なんです
しかし 過去を思い出すという修行もあります
瞑想実践によって精神的に向上する修行者は
達した位置について観察する
それから次に達するべき位置に位置を観察する
これだけなんです だから皆様には関係ないんです
で 瞑想すると 例えば禅定に達した
例えば第一覚りに達した
達したら本人がびっくりしますよ
ものすごく感動します
修行成功したと このびっくりすることを感動することの危険です
それで あれ 私の心に何が起きたのかと
再びその状況を観察するんです
それは過去を思い出すことなんです
それから私は何か精神的な経験を得ました
これはどんな経験ですかと
それによってどの程度で私の心が清らかになったのかと
どんなもののなくなったんですかと
これでまた残ってないのかと
煩悩が そういうふうに反省するんです
過去 これが特別な知恵なんです
これはパッチウェッカナーニャーナというふうに
知恵の一部としてお釈迦様の特典の特色の一つなんです
これがお釈迦様はみことにできる
上手なんです 誰もかなわないんです
だからブッダはブッダですよ
お釈迦様の弟子たちはどんな修行をしているのか
どんな境地に達しているのか
どこで失敗しているのか
これは明確に知っているんです
次にどんなレッスンを教えればよろしいかと
あるいは教えた瞑想のレッスンを変えた方がよろしいでしょうかと
お釈迦様が瞑想のレッスンをあげたら
絶対変えません 一回だけ
はい こういうふうに瞑想しなさいと
弟子たちがあなたにはこのレッスンはうまくいかないみたいね
じゃあレッスン変えましょうよと
結構変えますよ それはお釈迦様ほどパッチウェッカナーニャーナ
反省の知恵がないんだからなんです
だからお釈迦様がもう抜群
誰にもかなわないほどパッチウェッカナーニャーナ
ニャーナというのは智慧
反省の智慧持っているんです
だから これ大事なことで皆様に関係ないんですね
ですから まあもう2番目に言った方がいいと思います
関係ないと言っても 無私明照を実践する方々は
まあこれやってください
で やる時もちゃんと私がその場合言いますからね
いつでもやる必要はないんです
何かちょっと変わった上の経験が得た時
反省してみるんです 仏教は未だかつて問題を起こしてないのはそういうわけなんですよ
仏教の世界で我は悟ったそうとか
我がブッダそうとか 人を騙ったことはないんです
誰も ブッダはお釈迦様だけなんです
悟りに達するお坊さんたちはいくらでもいますけど
誰も知らない みんなまあボスだろうと一般的に扱います
でもなんだなく質問したら教えてくれそうなお坊さんだなとかね
わかりやすく説法するお坊さんだなとかね
私のことはなんか親みたいに可愛がってくれるんだ
心配してくれるんだとかね
その程度ではわかりますけど
本当に真珠のお坊さんたちがそれ以上何もしない
理由は反省しているんです
自分がどんな程度で精神的に上達したのか
それからまたどれぐらい残っているのかとよく知っているんです
いいふらしは絶対しないんです
報告は師匠にする 師匠は誰でもいいんで
教えてくれる能力あるとわかったら師匠にする
あるいは弟子たちにもする場合あります
弟子たちがまああんまり瞑想やる気もなくて
まあ適当にやればいいんじゃないかって思うと
あのね 実は私はこういう風にやって
こういう風にやって こういうこういうことを経験しているんだから
お前やりなさいと その場合はもう弟子に指導として言う場合もありますけど
それ以外は言わない だから
この結構皆様方 世の中はね
まあ仏教はなんでどんな組織でもね
100年ぐらい経つと腐っちゃいますよ
どうせ人間やっていることだからね
これ 2600年ですよ
もうまだ元気で しっかりしています
で それ一つ理由ことも一つ
一般人にはちょっとわからないんだけど
この反省の知恵 いつでも自分一人一人が反省の世界で生きているんです
だからこの出しゃばったり
見栄を張ったりはできません
が やっている人はいますよ
で 今日もインターネットでいろいろスリランカの仏教のことを調べたところでね
なんかちょっとまあ あるお坊さんをね
信者さんたちがもう奇跡を起こすお坊さんやとかね
本当にまあ立派なお坊さんで
説法はすごい上手で 説法はものすごく綺麗に説法する
ですから 私は別に まあ見た目もよろしいしね
私は見たら二度と見たくないという体ですけど
あのお坊さんがそうでもなくて
まあいいんじゃないかなと思いますけど
まあそれにブログで書いているところ
もうむちゃくちゃ書いてるんですね
だから結局仏教の国だから
あのお坊さんが奇跡を起こしましたよとか言ったっても
もう悪口言うことを言うんです
何やこれやと あんた奇跡を見せて仏教を広げたいんですかと
あれお釈迦様が禁止しているんだ
よく覚えておけと そこまで細切れに一度書くんです
そんなものに乗るのはアホ以外誰でもないんだよと
そういうふうにすごいもう無俗というか
だから自由ですよ 仏教の世界は
だから時々インチキ商売しようとする人々も結構います
でも それで仏教を破壊することは
そういう人々にできません
みんなばらしちゃいます
で そこはなぜかというと
この初期仏教の世界では
このやっぱりこの反省すべきというところね
よくあるんですよ しかし
この反省の意味 これから説明しますけど
皆様方は日本語でいう反省とは微妙に違うんです
自分が何者かと見ておくことなんですよ
別にこの何か 例えば今日の講演会が終わってからね
このスタッフの方々は
では反省会やりましょうって
それではないんです 時々私も呼ばれるんだけど
嫌なんです それは 呼ばないでください
で 終わったことだからね
で でも私も何がうまくいって
何がうまくいかなかったかと
それは調べます それからなんでうまくいったんですか？なんでうまくいかなかったんですかと
これ みんなの顔を見ないようなふりをしていますけど
一人一人はどんな程度でやっているか
どれぐらい結果が出しているのかって
やっぱりささっと見えちゃいますけどね
これは反省能力なんです
で 普通は皆様 会社で 家で
いろんなところでやってる反省は即席界的で
それはそれで構わないんですよ
しかし ただ反省ばっかしではなくて
ポジティブ的に次の実行に役に立てなくちゃいけないんです
だから仏教の反省っていうのは
この 2番目の意味でいくんです
実行の方へ はい では 2番目の意味に行きます
何の特別な意味もないんだけど
一応英語の有名なことわざを書いてみました THINK
BEFORE YOU JUMP
知ってますね それは やる前によく考えなさいという意味のことわざですね
伊勢にあったっけね  井戸があってね
かなり深い井戸で水がないんですね
このキツネさんが水を探しながら
まあバカですね もう井戸の中で水を見て飛んじゃったんです
飛んで水を飲んだんですけど
井戸から上がらないんですね
それでそこら辺はヤギさんがいたんですね
ヤギさんも喉が渇いて
で 井戸を見たら水があるんですね
あるんだけど なかなか飲めない
飲めない それで井戸の中からキツネさんがね
おい ヤギさん あんたどこ行くの？いっぱい水がありますよ
これすごい立派な水 汚れてないしね
おいしいんですよ あんたのどこか乾いてるでしょうにと言ったら
ヤギさんが水は飲みたいんだけど
私のベロは届かないですよと
お前バカじゃないかと
飛びなさいよと 中に そのままでは飲めませんと言ったら
ヤギさんが飛んじゃったんです
井戸の中に 飛んだらもう水はきれいな水があって
水を飲んで 飲んだ後 ヤギさんがね
水は飲んだんだけど どうやって戻れますかと
そうだな じゃあ方法ありますよと
あんたはもうもう立ってくださいと
壁に足をつけて それで私はあなたの体の上に立ってみたら
まあちょうどいいじゃない
ヤギさんがもう壁に立った
キツネがもう背中に乗って
もう立って飛んで出て行ったんです
出て行く前にヤギさんが
それあんた出て 私はどうするのかいと言ったら
キツネさんがあのね 飛ぶ前に考えなさいよと
飛ぶ前 跳ぶ前に考えなさいよということわざなんですね
まあそこは子供たちに理解するために
こういう面白い物語にするんですが
大事な意味なんですよ
実行する前に よく調べて考えてくださいということなんです
これがパッチウェーカラなんです
だからシンクビフォーユージャンプなんですね
これが正しいパッチウェーカラなんです
修行になるのはこの実践です
これ 面白いことを これが修行なんです
何かやる前に考えることっていうのは修行ですかね
これは正真正銘の仏教の修行なんです
あれはチンチリチンとかいろいろ鳴らしたりする
そんなのは仏教ではないんです
お数珠をチャリンチャリンと鳴らしたりとかね
でっかいシンボルをね
まあうるさいんですけどね
そういうような修行じゃないんですよ
これはテレビ向けの修行かもしれませんだけど
精神向上の何の関係もないんです
修行っていうのは しっかりと反省しながら生きてみることなんです
罪を犯すことなく 落ち込むことなく
堕落することなく 後悔することなく
日々成長する生き方になります
これでしょう 我々期待するのは
だったら何かやる前にちょっと考えてください
それだけ ちょっと喋る前にちょっと考えて
どうかなと これは何かやる前にこれでいいのかなと考えてみる
このわずかなことで 抜群に性格変わるんですよ
それで失敗 罪を犯すことなく落ち込む
落ち込んじゃうでしょ
私たちは 1 日 24時間ですね
まあ大体 30時間ぐらい落ち込んでるんです
まあ 1時間で落ち込めないほど落ち込むんですよ
レベルが重すぎですよ
だからニコニコと笑っていられないんですね
私も結構嫌われちゃいますからね
もう笑っちゃう よく笑うんだからね
まあこの間 あの  2回 あの 2回か 3回目行くはめになったんです
あの 亡くし 誰か亡くなってね
あの 7日の法要に 人は死んだばっかりだからね
誰もまあ笑う気にはならないんですね
それでこれ ただで便利で捕まるバカ坊主がいるんだからね
私にあの まあお坊さん
あの説法をお願いします
法事をお願いします 私は嫌やと
いろいろ仕事がありまして
忙しくてね もう年寄りの説法できんやろと断ったんだけど
やっぱりもう行く人がいなくてね
行ってまず言ったんですよ
あんた方はね まあ安く手に入るんだからって言って
私を捕まったんですけどね
後で後悔するぞと 言って説法したんですが
まあむちゃくちゃみんな笑わせたんですよ
まあ死んだ まあ死んだ人が来ていたらば笑うだろうと思いますけどね
やっぱり仏教って明るいんですよ
人が死んでもね まあ明るくもう法要してこうする
泣き崩れたりはしません
で  1回目はみんななんかいい加減でだらしなくてね
それから私はものすごい厳しく
もう二度とあんた方の誰の家にも行かないんだよと
行儀が悪いんだと で 怒ったらみんな怖くなっちゃって
まあ次の法事 別な家なんですけど
そちら一応真剣真面目にいたんですね
まだ別な地方でも同じ 7日目の法事に行ってね
まあそこは特別に これはこのお坊さんに頼んで説法しますからということで
たくさん人々が来ていて
このは亡くなったお母さんの法要ではなくて
説法を聞きたいということで来てて
真面目に聞きましたけど
そこでたくさん冗談を言いましたけど
それは大丈夫ですけど
自分のお寺の村なんで
問題は まあ私は何やっても笑っちゃいますから
ものすごい嫌われてるんです
嫌われて私がよく怒るんだと言うんです
どういう脳細胞かよくわかりません
で とにかくこの 自分のことをよく下にしておけば
明るく生活できます もう笑っちゃいます
たとえ失敗したっても
なんで失敗したのかと調べるでしょ
そうすると まあこのアホはこういうことをいつでもやってるんだけど
どうったことないでしょうと
あ またやっちゃったんだからとかね
これ自分に笑えますよ
で 私はよく物を忘れちゃいますね
もう置いた何か置いたら
そのままそこはもう忘れて出ていくんですね
で これ 自分持っていたものは必ず持って帰らなくちゃいけないってことは知ってるんだけど
なんか机の上に置いた時点で自分のものでなくなっちゃうんですね
おかしいんです だけどそのまま帰っちゃうんです
しかし 必要なものでしょ
だから日本ではあまりやらないんだけど
スリランカではやっぱり誰か誰かが後ろから行かないと大変なんです
私は忘れるものをまた持って帰らないと
時々お寺から借りたものを
これもう貸してよと言って貸して
またどこかに 例えば説法に何か丸い何か持ってきますよ
うちわみたいなもの で
これ持ってないんで 私は
かわいそうですね あれ
高いからじゃなくて あんなのはまあお寺ではね
まあふさわとは言います
安いんだから 信者さんお布施するわするわ
もう見ただけでもまあ結構やと思いますけど
だからまあお寺から一つ貸してと借りますけど
どこかの在家の人の家に行って説法したら
それはそのまま置いといて
私は帰ります もう俺に関係ないんだと
それで誰かが後ろからこれを持ってお寺に戻さないと
それで私が言うのは もし何かそうやって必要な品物がなくなって
もうもう消えちゃったら
あれはどうなったんでしょうかね
この間 あなた そうなんですけど
私が借りた 貸す 貸す 借りた覚えありますよと言うんです
私は でもどこに置いたか覚えてないんだから
これはあなた方のせいでしょうにと
私に聞くなよと なんで私はどこかに置いておいたら
それをもうもう持ってこなかったんですかと
だから財布も忘れますけど
だからもし忘れたら運転手に怒鳴るんです
お前のせいだと そう よくそう言うんだから
みんなそれ知って これが起こっていると思ってますけど
親しく親しくいる人々はそう思ってないんです
みんなもう結構楽しく
まあこの人とはもう大変やと
お世話してキリがないんだという感じでやってます
ですから 日本にいるのは大変です
私にとって全部自分でやらなくちゃいけないんだから
はい  そういうことを言ったのは
やっぱりこの 自分の状況をよく知っておけば
落ち込む必要ないんです
それ冗談に回せばいいんです
例えば旦那さん 奥さんがスイスイ衝動的に高いものでも何でも買っちゃいますと
これ分かったら 旦那さんと買い物に行く
そしたらもうあんた財布をちゃんと握っておいてくださいと
もし私が高い買い物したらあんたのせいですと
言っておけば夫婦は楽しいでしょうに
その場合は 奥さんが余計な高い買い物しちゃって
お金がなくて 旦那も二人で困ったのではなくて
奥さん いや あなたのせいですよ
それは私のせいじゃないんだと
と言っちゃえば もう自分の性格をあらわにしているし
つい衝動で買ってしまう
それを知ったら 旦那さんが財布をその時は大事に
持っていく 持ってて高い買い物を買おうとしたっても
私はお金やりませんよと言えば
それでもう もう問題は解決
ですから これで軽く生きていられますよ
半生 人生は それから我々の狙いも
落ち込むことなく 後悔することなく
罪を犯すことなく生きることでしょう
これはできます はい これで一つのセクション終わりまして
次のセクションに行きます
できそうもない 正しい自己診断
失敗する可能性が高いんですよ
自己診断すると 何か話がまとめてないような気がするでしょう
また後悔する羽目になりました
で この自己診断っていうのは
これなんかセルフカウンセリングみたいなもんですね
セルフカウンセリングといったらちょっとおかしいんですよ
カウンセリングっていうのは誰かと話し合うことなんですね
自分で質問して 自分で答えるというね
自己診断っていうのは
一応セルフカウンセリングみたいなもんです
まずは一回ぐらい自己診断してみれば
すべてうまくいくという誤解があるんです
我々は自己診断できれば
これで OK というふうに思ってるんです
それが誤解なんです すべての人は自分のことを最大に評価しているんです
どんな人でも世界一誰ですかと聞いたら
俺のことだと言うんです
そう思ってるんです 世界一一番大事な人は誰ですかと言うと自分なんです
だから世界一大事な自分が自分を判断すると
判断すると思う 判断すると高く評価するんです
だからこれできそうもないことなんです
それからこの高慢 卑下慢の人もいるでしょ
卑下慢の人 私はどうったことはないと思っている人いるでしょ
あれも自分が最大の価値ある生き物やという前提の上で成り立っているんです
だから本気じゃないんです
私は何の役にも立たないゴミみたいな人間ですよという人は
あれ嘘言ってるんです
本気じゃないんです 私は役に立たない人間だと思って悩む場合も
私は最高の価値があるものだという気持ちの表れです
私は負けたことがないんだそうと言ったら
自分が高く評価しているでしょ
逆に私は勝ったことは一度もないんだよと言ったっても
同じ気持ちなんです だからダメ
ダメ ダメ やりませんよと
ということは負けたくはないでしょう
あんた勝ったこと一度もなかったならば
珍しくないでしょ もう一度やってくださいと
これはうまくいかないんです
ダメってことあるんです
結局負けたくないんです
で 私はこれ 子供たちに時々教えたりしますけどね
子供たちは遊ぼうと呼ぶんですね
どんな遊びと聞いたら
まあ年寄りにはちょっと敵わないんですね
子供は 私は何か負けそう
先に負けそうとわかったら
私はいきなり嫌ですと言うんです
嫌です そんなそんな遊びはと
なんでと 面白いよ で 面白いと君たちがむちゃくちゃ買っちゃったりしてね
私は俺こそに負けるでしょうにと
だから嫌ですよと言ったら
みんな心配して みんな話し合ってよくわかりました
あの 何とかしますからと
で なんかみんなでからくりをして
私は勝てるようにしてあげると
だから嫌ですよと言うんで
私は あんた方はいろいろ手を抜いたりしてね
私は勝たせてあげたのも
これまたかっこ悪いでしょうにと
というわけで断りますと
そこで私は 子供たちは何を言いたがっているかで
自分が決して負けたくはないというプライド高い人やと
もう言ってるんです なんでそれを子供たちにわざわざと負けるのは大丈夫と言うのは
やっぱり人間の心がそういうふうにできているんだということを子供たちに教えてあげたいんです
基本的には自分のことを高く評価しているんだよと
はい これで私は何を言いたいかというと
皆様にあの 自己判断する方法を教えたっても
皆様方はとんでもないことをすると思いますよ
自分のことは最大に評価しちゃうんです
それがこの私は最高な生き物です
世界で一番大事な生き物は誰ですか？と言ったら
俺は俺ですなんです これってどう考えたっておかしい考えでしょ
でも本音です これは ですから
本音は隠すんです この人間のだけじゃなくて
生命の本音は本当にとんでもないことでしょう
私はこの動物たち調べると結局同じなんです
動物は動物で自分こそ偉いと思っているんです
で 皆様方はね 犬やら猫やら自分のことを可愛がってくれると思ってるでしょ
ああ 可愛い可愛いとかね
でも騙されてますよ 犬も猫も本音隠してるんです
で 私はだいたい動物を管理しないで対等で扱ってみるんです
そうすると何のことなく本音バレるんです
普通は動物はお腹が空いたらなんか餌ちょうだいという風な顔をするでしょ
私の場合 私の顔をじっと見て
あんた何やってるの？餌くれよという顔をするんです
餌くれよと だからそこを本音
もう丸出しなんですね
これが私に可愛いんですよ
この可愛い顔をしないでもうもう偉い調子で要求する
私のベッドに寝たくなったら
私はどけてあげなくちゃいけないんです
犬なんかもう蹴るんですよ
あっちにうるさいやと
自分のベッドなんですけど
それで本音出すんです
だからまあ その時本当にリラックスしてますから
しょうがないんだけど
だからこれはこの動物にもありますし
我々人間にもありますし
自分こそ一番偉いっていうこういう気持ちはね
これが本音です 皆様言ってる本音じゃないんで
これは本当の本音です
これを隠すんです 隠さなきゃうまくいかないんです
自我価値 いわゆるこれ
自我価値なんですね セルフエプリシエーションは隠しておいた方が良いんです
で 常識的な人間は本音を隠します
精神的正常状態が壊れた人に自我価値を隠せなくなります
これ隠せない 隠すできない人間
今だ病気です いつでも我々は優しく
正しく 行儀よく振る舞い振る舞うんですよ
本当にやりたくないんです
やりたくないんだけど
しっかりとしきたりを守って
行儀作法を守って生きているんです
だから すーっと本音を隠しているんです
それが正常です もし本音を隠さないで
なんだこれ なんで私はあなたに挨拶しなくちゃいけないんですか？という調子になってくると
病気ですよ これ危険です
皆 巨大な精神病を持って生きているが
幸いに発病しないように管理しているんです
だから我々一人一人が恐ろしい精神病を持っています
これは我こそ偉いという病気なんです
他誰でもなく我こそ偉い
これが巨大な精神病気ですけど
とにかく頑張って頑張って
私たちは発病しないようにしているんです
はい これで私は何を言いたいかというと
この今日のテーマは自己診断なんですけど
これは無理です こんな自分こそ一番偉い
高いと思いつつ 自分で自分を診断するときは正直でしょ
誰かに診断して それを見せるならばごまかすんです
自分のために診断する場合は正直に診断しますよ
この正直がおかしいんです
人間の正直っていうのは
自分が一番偉いっていうことなんです
だから正しく言えば これ無理です
という理由で 正しい自己診断
現実的には無理です しかし
生きている上で自己制御は欠かせないんですよ
無理だといっても 我々はなんとか自分をコントロールしなくちゃいけない
それで自分をチェックする必然性が当然あるのです
なんか矛盾ですよ だって自己診断はできない
が やらなくてはいけない
だって自分でちゃんと自分をコントロールしていないと何するかわからないでしょう
といっても 自分では診断することもできない
これがなんとか解決しなくちゃいけない
この問題は どのように気をつけるべきでしょうか
ということでね  この問題
これ矛盾ですよ これどうすればいいかと
ちょっと早く飛ばさないと
はい 次のチェックリストというテーマにします
自己診断のためにチェックリストを使う
これは当然他人が作るものです
チェックリストは誰かが作るんです
しかし 完全なリストは世の中にないんです
他人が自分の研究テーマに沿ったリストを作ります
恋愛 人間関係 IQなどをチェックするリストがあります
心理学者の人々はいろいろな分野で研究しています
この自分を研究する分野に合わせてチェックリストを作るんです
例えば 恋愛について恋愛について研究する人は
そのリストだけに 人間関係で関係研究する人は
それに関わるリストだけで
だから世の中でチェックリストはあるんだけど
全部この専門ごとに分かれていて
完全なリストはないんです
それから宗教もチェックリストを作るんです
これも完全じゃないんです
各宗教にも自分の教えに沿ったチェックリストがあります
宗教の教えは互い違いなので
このタイプのリストに一貫性はないんです
宗教が提案する自己診断リストも一貫性はないんです
例えば キリスト教が素晴らしい人間だと判断する人が
イスラム教の信者さんがそう判断しません
サタンの輩と判断するんです
だから中東の国々は アメリカはサタンの国やと言うんです
アメリカ人は自分の国だけが神の国だと思っているんです
他は野蛮の国だと どうもなんか一貫性がないんです
冗談の例で言えば 豚肉を食べるべきか
食べてはいけないかというような問題なんです
イスラム教にユダヤ教によると
豚肉食べたらもう悪人ですね
汚れが人間です 心汚れていて
自分は地獄に行くんです
キリスト教にしてみれば
別にという感じ もうものすごく食べてるんです
どの肉を食べてもいいんじゃないかと
だからこのチェックリストはそれぞれ変わってしまいますね
宗教の教えによって だから宗教が偉いんだからね
と言っても 提供するリストは全然役に立ちません
ゴミです 個人はどのリストにするか
また自分で判断しなくてはならないんです
また個人に問題がかかってくる
私は自己診断したければ
無数のリストの中でリスト一つ二つか選ばなくちゃいかんですよ
これまた自分で判断するんだから
自分の都合でうまくいかないんです
その判断 間違ったらチェックは無駄になります
だから自分でリストを探すんだから
二重丸 かける質問リストを探すんです
これは二重丸 これも二重丸
これもバツ これもバツと言われるリストは
これはいいですと断ります
だから自分がリストを選ぶんだけど
自己診断できないリストを選ぶんです
高く評価できるリストを選ぶんだから
どうにもならん この問題は
リストの問題 完全ではないことと多数が存在することだけではありません
リスト一つも完全ではない
また あるいはあるいはあるいはあるいは
時々学校に入学する時でも
性格を分析する質問書を出すんですよ
会社でも時々そういう質問書を出すんです
これに答えてくださいと
あれに答えると 自分の性格をチェックしているんです
学校と会社でやります
そういうことで多数あります
それから一つの感染じゃないんです
リストに質問に答えて
満点になっても 性格はまるっきりその通りやとはわからないんです
リストを作る人は心の動き
性格構成などは知り尽くしているのかという問題です
我々は一部研究するんであって
全体的に何も知らないんですよ
あのでしたっけ メダカの研究する科学者はメダカについては知ってますけど
マグロのことを知らないんです
全くも そんなもんなんです
世の中は だからメダカの研究者に魚を理解するための質問リストを書いてくださいと頼んだらどうなるんですかね
メダカについてリストを作るでしょ
だから世の中にある自己診断リストはそういうわけで信頼できないことになっています
リストを持つ時点で 自分の人生は他人に任せたことになるんです
私はどこかの心理学者のところに行って
あの先生 私は私のことを自分で判断しますから
どこをチェックするべきかと
何かマニュアルくださいと
言うと 先生から本をもらいます
マニュアル そちらに質問があるんです
それを持った時点で 私はあのリストを作った人に操られているんです
だって答え書いてますからね
この質問には ABCDE ありまして
Cと答えた人はすぐ怒る性格ですと裏書いてます
だから操られているんです
他人は自分のことを心配するのでしょうか？それで世の中は医者もいるし
心理カウンセラーもいるし
いるわ いるわ 教師もいるし
課長もいるし 社長もいるし
この世の中の人々は本当に私のことを心配するんですかね
心配しないでしょ 人のこと
だから人に頼ったらひどい目に遭います
自分のことは全然心配しない人を
なんで拝んで そのリストに身を任すんですかね
自分がリストを作る時も
世間の考えを参考にしなくてならないって
また矛盾があるんです
では わかりました 私が私がリストを作ります
私の診断書 自分で作りますと言ったら
どんな質問すればいいんですかね
また参考しなくちゃあかんでしょ
では あの本を見ます この本を見ますとかやっちゃいますよ
ですから 結局は人の意見になるんです
あの有名な心理学者の本を読んでから
私は質問を作ります チェックリストを作りますと言っちゃうと
結局はあの有名な心理学者が自分を管理しているんです
だから これがまあ無理な話です
結局はチェックリストは
はい これで一応準備に対する準備としての知るべきことはまあ全部書きました
この立ち上げからについて
なんで書いたのかということで疑問が
なんで反省っていうものは書いたんですかね
自己診断でしょ 今日のテーマは
だから理論はこういう理論なんです
自己診断は無理です だから諦めなさいと
余計なことするなよと
忘れてくださいと その代わりに反省しなさいと
これで完璧解決ですっていうことです
まず皆様に宿題を出します
私はずっと一人で難しい経典を読んで
この経典何読んだって
もう出家弟子たちに解脱に達する目的で一貫して語られているんですよ
これ参考にして 私はあの
何といいますか 結婚相手が見つからないと悩んでいる女の子に
若者に説法しなくちゃいけないんです
どんなことをどういうことかと
旦那さんが浮気しているんですから
私の何が悪いんですかと
奥さん聞くでしょ 私は解脱に達するべき経典を読んで
これに答えなくちゃあかんですね
じゃあ私の苦労もちょっと理解していただいて
今日は教えてあげません
自己診断書これから出します
これは出家の自己診断書
これで解脱を目指しています
経典の名前はダサダンマスって １０
項目の経典という名前です １０
項目の教え 項目１０です
簡単です この１０をチェックしてくださいと
出家に対して作戦が説かれたリストです
在家の役に立たないが
これ役に立ちません 出家が人格向上して解脱に達する道を成功する目的で説かれたんです
この１０項目は だらしない人間が
ろくでもない人間が出家して
日々成長して人格完成者になるんです
それにお釈迦様が人格チェックする自己診断リスト
チェックリストを作ったんです
自分のチェックリストを作る時
参考にするのかとチェックしてください
参考になるのかと はい
これから皆様の宿題 私は項目を説明します
これは私の場合は役に立ちますかね
どう使えばよろしいかねとか
ご自分で判断してください
常に観察するべき項目
この時初めてお釈迦様がパッチウェッカティという言葉が専門用語として初めてではないんですけど
専門用語として使います
だから反省とは自己診断なんです
だからなんか最初はなんか私が勘違いしているように見えたはずでしょ
でもこれ勘違いしたわけじゃなくて
反省とは自己診断することなんです
反省はできます ですから反省する方法できます
第１の項目 私はかっこ悪い姿になったのですと反省する
反省するっていうことは
あーもったいないことしまったではないんです
あれは後悔する 振り返って思い出す
私はかっこ悪い姿になったんだからね
という調子です これは皆様にはどうやって役に立ちますかね
パリゴダウェーワンニャンミアジュパガトーティ
パッバジテーナアビンハンパッチャウェッキタッバ
パッチャウェッカナパッチャウェッキタッバ
アビンハン 常にいつでも繰り返し
私はかっこ悪くなっちゃったなあとかね
かっこ悪くなったよという
すごい調子よく反省するんです
後悔するんじゃないんです
これは皆様の俗世間には役に立つか立たないかという宿題ですね
あれは答えません この意味は
出家はおしゃれしないんです
日曜日はこの服 火曜日はこの服
水曜日はこの服 木曜日はこの服
金曜日はまた日曜日の服を繰り返すとかはないんです
朝も昼も夜も同じ服なんです
髪型どうするのかはないんです
カリスマ美容師美容師に行きますか？とかね
まあ今度は渋谷ではなくて
どこでした？代々木でどこでしたっけ？まあありますね
結構若者がね 集まって集まって
美容師たちがいてね 今度はこの店
次はあの店とかないんです
体をアピールしない 質素な生き方になりましたという意味なんです
はい 私は体肉体をアピールしない生き方をしています
私が生きるべき方はこの生き方ですと
これどういうことかというと
たとえ出家しても 自分と同じ歳の人々がかなりおしゃれして
帽子も被って イギリス人みたいに杖を回しながら
またはすごい美人の女の人と手を組んで
歩く 自分と同じ年なんですね
もしかすると自分と同じ同級生かもしれません
そうするとなんとなく気分がね
変わる可能性あります
私にはこれやりたいんだけどね
俺だてもっとかっこいい男でしたけど
アイスよりはと あいつより私がモテたのにね
今私が復帰したんだから調子乗りやがっちゃってとかね
私も好きが好きでした
女女ですけどとかね そういうふうに思っちゃうと
自分の心が汚くなりまして
自分が決めた道を失敗する
今出家するそうと出家したでしょ
失敗する 皆様にもよくありますね
学校終わってから入社試験を受けて会社に入るでしょ
半年で辞めますね 結構いるでしょ
今は半年で 1 年で辞める
情けないでしょ 自分が会社で仕事するんだよと決めたのに
途中で腰を上げて負けてくる
こんなのは仏教は絶対認めません
負けは絶対認めません
決めたらやりなさいと
成功するまで でも決めたんだけど
やりたいんだけど これ大変やと
知ったことじゃないんだ
そんなのは大変だとかね
暑すぎだとかね 寒すぎだとかね
そんなのは知ったことじゃないんだよと
例えば電力会社で外の技術屋さんで管理する
北海道で あるいは東北の方で
真冬 それで雪が降りすぎちゃって
もうトランスフォーマーがイカれちゃって
壊れて 電線が壊れた そのまま放っておくわけにいきませんでしょ
人々死んじゃいますからね
だからさっさとまた新しいトランスフォーマーつけて
電線を引いて 人々に電力を供給供給しなくちゃいかんですよ
こんな吹雪でできるわけないだろうと言える
いくら吹雪であっても
車が行けないところであっても
なんとかしてあの電信柱に乗って
送魔を入れ替えて 電線を引いて電気をつなげてあげなくちゃかんです
だから決めた仕事はやるんですよ
人間なら 文句言わない
寒いとか 給料は少ないとか
情けないんですよ まあ隠れて給料は少ないんだから
そのうちいい仕事に飛んでやるぞと思うのは
それは別な話で そのうちいい仕事に飛びますけど
今の仕事はしっかりやる
そういう性格ですから
仏教では出家したら負けたらあかん
でお釈迦様がすごく優しいんだから
負けないようにと何か微妙に助けてくれるんです
これは第一チェック これなんです
だから友達がね かっこいい女の子と手を組んで
据え回しながら 偉そうに貴夫人みたいに
もうどこかにデートに行くときは
まあ俺はかっこ悪い姿になったんだからね
まあ関係ない そんなのはと
そこで心は汚れないで
無執着のままでいるんです
誰がなんか 2万円  3万円も値段かかるネクタイをつけている
見る限りすごい美しい
ああ 嫌だな 私にはね ネクタイはつけられないね
この衣を着ているんだからだ
悩まないんです  俺はこんな形だからね
ネクタイはいらんねというふうに反省するんです
自分を観察する 私にはいらん
こんなのはと だから何をと
例えば自分の友達がもう 3万円のネクタイなのに
その真ん中にピンを刺しているね
これダイヤが 300万円のダイヤのピンがついて
悔しいでしょうね 悔しくないんです
なんだ お前その石までつけてるんですかと
俺にはね 石もつける必要ないね
いうことで えらくリラックスを感じるんです
これが出家のやり方で
皆様にも裏ヒントがあります
日常でああ やれやれ 俺はダメだなと思う瞬間でどうするのかと
2番目 他人に頼って高瀬ですね
生きる羽目になりましたと
あのインドではすごい誇りに思うんですよ
自分で仕事をして稼ぐ
を養うこと あの人からちょっと金くれませんかっていうのは
もう情けない卑しい生き方やとすごく非難するんです
生活補助であれの手当
これの手当で 時々ね 事故があったり
災害に遭ったりして助けてもらう時はありますけど
それは構わないんだけど
さっさと自立して自分で生きることが仏道で高く評価するんです
これこそかっこいい生き方だと
いう仏教は出家したらあえて反対の生き方させるんです
托鉢で生活しなさいと
いわゆる乞食でいいでしょ
世界で一番かっこ悪い生き方
私はこの生き方をしているんだと反省します
いわゆる反省っていうのは落ち込む反省じゃなくて
私はこういうこういう者ですという意味なんです
私は人からもらって食べるものです
仕事も何もない もうそんな立場じゃありませんと
いわゆる社会人ではありませんと
社会に入る資格もない人間ですと言って
胸を張って自分を反省する
これは何のためかというと
この自我をなくすためなんです
俺が世界一偉いという
あの最大の病気を治す治療なんです
あんた何者か ただの乞食でしょうにと
自分のこと この威張ったり
我は偉いと思ったり 何考えてるんですかと
ただの不良者でホームレスで乞食だろうと
というふうに自分を反省する
これが 2番目のチェックポイントなんです
しきたり 生活習慣などは世間とは違います
私の生き方 食べる時間
歩き方 あれやこれや 何でもかんでも俗世間の決まりとは違いますと
例えば 親戚が子供の誕生パーティーをやります
そこでカラオケで歌ったり
いろいろ踊ったりする
自分もその親戚なんです
でも 自分には何一つもやってはいけないんです
カラオケで歌うことも
はい お誕生日おめでとうございます
はい ではケーキカットしましょうとかなんとかとか
本当は禁止です 行ったならば
頼まれたら行っても構わないんだけど
黙っているしかないんです
はい ではみんなでハッピーバースデー
黙っていなくちゃあかんです
絶対ハッピーバースデーチュー言うてはいけません
だからしきたり すべて違います
ということは 俗世間には嫌がられるわ
嫌われるわ キリがないんです
これがかっこいいんです
俗世間はあなた方は来るな
インド文化では大事なことをするときは
坊主に会ったらやめなさいと
そこまで私たちのことを嫌がらせするんです
もしあなたが大事な旅を出るときは
最初に頭剃っている出家に出会ったら
たちまちその旅をやめなさいと
嫌われていること そこで出家が落ち込むかというと
馬鹿に嫌われてよかったと
迷信だらけの連中に嫌われてよかったと威張るんです
逆に まず嘘でしょうし
お坊さん だから仏教の人々はいつでもお坊さんの姿を見たいんです
この 2日 3日前 私は朝
本堂に行って法華あげようかなと数珠払いに行こうかなと言ったら
なんか人々大騒ぎしているんですね
見たら なんか若い男の子と女の子がおしゃれをしてきて
あちら行って写真撮る
こっちでこの結婚式 みんな結婚衣装を着ているんですね
だからどういうことかと言ったら
まあこの村の人々は結婚式が始まる前に
全部お嫁さんの服を着て
旦那さんも服を着て ハネムーンに行く車に乗って
...お寺に来て お寺でちょこちょことあちらこちらで遊んで
それから自分の家で披露になるんです
そこで まあ私から見ればまあ若いし
子供でしょうし こいつらにちょっとお経でもあげて祝福した方がいいんじゃないかなと思ってね
もう無理にお前ら写真ばっかり撮るんじゃなくて
こっち来いと言って祝福したんですけど
で で 私がまたお経 私の住手もて帰ると
また他のグループ来るんですね
だからスリランカの場合は逆にやっぱりお寺でちょっと一回りして遊んだ方が幸福だなと思ってるんです
気持ちはいいんだと まあだから迷信は迷信で
とにかく出家はしきたりは違います
在家のしきたりはやりません
もし出家がそれをやったならば
情けないんです 失敗者なんです
我々はやりませんと言って堅守でいるんです
だから それもよく反省する項目です
四 私の両親は道徳に対して訴えてないのでしょうか？と考えてみる
私の両親 人にバレなくても
悪いことしたら自分の両親が知ってるでしょう
ですから 自分の心が自分に訴えているのかい？と反省してみるんです
道徳戒律を守ること項目ですね
五 出家の仲間が戒律に対して私を訴えることをしないのでしょうかと
かなり気をつけるんです
お坊さんたちに訴えられないように気をつけますと
六 すべての好むもの 好きなものから離れていくことが必ず起こるのですと
この世の中で好きなものを必要なものは愛するものはすべて消えちゃいますよと
すべて置いて私が死にますよと
すーっと反省するんです
もう何かとても 例えばすごい健康でいいお寺で住むことになりましたと
健康なんですけど これがなくなりますよと
いいお寺出るんだけど
他のお寺に行く羽目にもなりますよと
森の中に生活する羽目になるかもしれませんとか
いつでもそこは反省する
七 業によって生まれ 業に頼って業を相続している
私の善悪行為は私は相続することになるのですと
7番目の反省の項目です
8番目 日夜私はどのように過ごしているのでしょうかと反省する
九 私は孤独の出家生活を気に入っているのでしょうかと
時々嫌になるかもしれませんよ
ですから 私はこの生活は気に入っているのか
気に入っているのかとよく反省してみるんです
10番目 私に人間の次元を超えた何かの超越した聖者にふさわしい経験はあるのでしょうか
出家してむちゃくちゃ長生き長生きしたんだけど
何か精神的にありますかね
私には 得たものはと反省してみるんです
臨終の際 修行者がそれを尋ねるとき
黙っていることになるのでしょうかと
あの仏教の場合は 最後にどんな言葉をかければいいかと
私にも結構聞かれますね
今 おじい様が倒れてもう危ないんだと
どんな言葉をかければいいでしょうかと
もう私はわかりません
そのおじいさんのことは
だから どんな言葉をかければおじいさんが喜ぶかわかりませんだからね
仏教の場合は今はあまりやらないんだけど
お坊さんがもう死にかけている
それで看病する人々は
頑張ってください 頑張ってくださいと言わないんです
あんたもうそろそろ死ぬでしょうと
もう後がないみたいと
それで何か出家修行して
何か価値あるものに達したことありますかと
あなた無駄で死ぬんですか？何か精神的に何か向上したものを得て死にますかと聞くんですよ
もう死にかけて大変状態なんですけど
その時はまあ修行はまあ 40年もしましたけど
そんなの何もないんだとと言う羽目になると恥ずかしいと言うと
だからそれは日々反省してみるんです
これは 10項目です これは素晴らしい項目です
なぜかというと ブッダが少学者の知恵で語ったんです
この項目は 釈尊はあれ禁止
これ禁止というようなモラリストではありません
見事に人を成長するようにとこのチェックリストを作ったんです
あんた 日夜チェックしてください
このリスト これ自己診断書だと
すごいいたって簡単でしょ
ただチェックするだけ
私の日夜はどのように過ごするのでしょうか
といえば 朝はご飯食っちゃって
それから寝て 昼はなになにさんと無駄話をして
それで昼ご飯を食べて
それから昼寝して それから散歩に行って
公園の犬と遊んでから
まあ夜はテレビを見て
今寝るとなったらどうですかね
まあ情けないものありゃしないでしょ
だから私の昼夜はどのように過ごしているものなのかと反省すると
心理学的に見てください
見事に人格が変わるんです
あ こんなこと言ってはいられる場合じゃない
こんなふざけてる場合じゃない
今日は自慢できるものを何かしなくちゃとかね
経典 1個でも勉強しなくちゃとか
わずかな時間でも何か瞑想しなくちゃとか
なんとか今日はこれやりましたよというようなことをするんですよ
からだそう だからこのその項目 8
番だと思いますけど 皆様もそのまま使ってください
私の日夜はどう過ごしてるんですかねとかね
それ頭で反省していると
立派な日夜に自動的になるんですよ
若者はふざけて遊ぶと年寄りは落ち込む必要ないんですよ
私のあれは私の世界じゃないんだからね
関係ない そんなのはと
まあ捨てた世界やと思うと気持ちいいんですよ
立派な年寄りになれるんです
で 一応使えますよ 難しいんですが
使い方は今日説明しません
心を知り尽くして どのように管理すれば解脱に達するのかと知った上で確かめた上で語られているのです
個人のリストも禁止項目とやるべき項目ではなく
心そのものを改良するリストにしなくてはならないのです
皆様もこれからチェックリストを作るんですけど
私は朝これやります これは絶対やりませんとか
このやる TO DO リストとしてはいけない
リスト作らないでください
気持ち悪い そんなのは
レベル低い タバコを吸わないことにしましたとかね
やるべきこと 朝五時に起きることにしました
なんかレベルが低いんです
なぜならば 人生はそんなにリストで完了することはできませんよ TODO
リストってどこまであるのかわかったんですかね
してはいけないことっていくらでもあるでしょうね
これからもあれがあるでしょうね
今 例えば麻薬あるでしょ
で 皆さんも私は麻薬を使わないことに決めましたと
もしかすると将来は音楽を通して酔うようにするかもしれませんよ
あの特別な波を作って
音楽と一緒にそこを流すスピーカーで
そこが耳で取って脳に信号が行ったら
脳は麻薬効果が作るとか
どうする？そうするとまた新しいやってはいけないリストが入るでしょ
私はそういう系の音楽は聞きませんとかね
こんなやりきれない そんなのは
ですから そういうリストじゃなくて
あの十項目参考にして
自分が日々成長するリスト
成長するためにチェックするポイントを書くんです
で これからあの在庫のリストに入りますけど
佐藤さん じゃあちょっと皆様疲れていらっしゃるんですから
ちょっと十分程度休憩します
はい では始まります はい
これからあの在庫の自己診断リストになります
で 心の性質を改良する
この自己診断リスト 仏教の自己診断リストの特色は
何かをやってはいけない
あれやりなさいではなくて
この心の状況をね 改良するんです
行動は自由です 管理しない
例えば性格のいい子供なら
あれやるなよ これやるな
いたずらするなよ 人を蹴るなよと言う必要ないでしょ
性格の悪い子にはあれやってはいけない
これやってはいけない
ちゃんと練習しないと
もう無限のリストを挙げなくちゃいかんですよ
だから子供に無限のリストを挙げるよりは
心を変える 改良すれば簡単でしょ
それから勝手にしなさいと言っちゃえば終わり
少ないようにしなさい
あんたは  はい そういうやり方なんです
で これ この場合はカーラムスッタという経典使います
アンクトルニカー的なパートの
まあこれはいいですね
有名な経典ですが 皆人の話を鵜呑みにするなかれという十項目にしか興味がないようです
このカーラム経典といえば
もしかするともう教会でも本出しているようだと思いますし
むちゃくちゃもう参考にして説法するわ
英訳もたくさんあるし
インターネット見ても結構あります
ヨーロッパでも結構人気あります
この経典 なぜかというと
この世界で初めてこの物事を鵜呑みにするなよと
聖典だからといって信じるなよと
神の言葉だと言ったってもね
そんなの信じるなよと
理屈に合いますよと だからといって信じるなよ
たとえあなた方に今喋っている釈迦牟尼ブッダである自分が
インドではとても有名人で
みんなに信頼されているんだからといって
信じるなよと言っていることは
その理由で自分で判断しなさい
自分で観察しなさいという十項目あるんです
これが爆発的な人気で
経典の本文は誰も気にしないみたい
しかし この経典の本文は在家に対する自己診断書なのです
気づかない心の衝動 心は貪瞋痴の衝動で
エネルギーで動いているのです
誰の心も貪瞋痴で生きているんです
だからもう普通の心じゃないんですよ
誰でもやることはおかしいし
貪瞋痴ですから で これ貪瞋痴っていうのはいくらかわかりやすい波長で
もっと裏に無明といって
また自我といってね もっともっとなんかもう混沌した
もうカオスみたいな感情があるんです
それが最初に説明した我こそ偉いという気持ちなんです
そこから貪瞋痴が生まれてきて
これで心に基本的にそれあるんですよ
これで生きているんです
だからつい嘘をついちゃうでしょ
そこで世間的には嘘をつくなかれと項目を作るんです
こんな項目を作ったって嘘をつくんです
欲しいものがあったらすぐ取っちゃいます
それがまずいんだから盗むなかれと項目を作るんです
この盗むなかれとどんな宗教でも言ってますけど
でもみんな盗んでるんです
どうにもならない だからこのお釈迦様はこの心そのものを改良するんです
あまりリストは気にしない
なかれのリストとするべきであるリストは気にしない
そんなのどうでもいいやと
どうでもいいやという意味じゃなくて
これ誤解する場合もありますけど
例えば心から欲がなくなったら
人のものを盗まないでしょ
盗むなかれと もうこちらではじめから書く必要はないんです
盗まない 人と喧嘩するなかれと
怒りが出てこなきゃ喧嘩しないでしょうに
ですから 心を基本的なところ
衝動を直せばいいんです
そのためのリストなんです
日常起こる 欲 怒り 嫉妬
落ち込み 恨み 悩み 慢などは知ってます
これは皆様知っています
日常は恨みが出てくるわ
落ち込んだりするわ 怒るわ
欲が出るわって 日常の感情は知っています
それ制御しようと努力もします
皆様方 今日の話を聞かなくても
日本中皆様方は 仏教に興味が全くなくても
怒らないように頑張ってます
欲張らないようには頑張っているんです
盗まないようには頑張っているんです
よく理解してください
我々わかっている 怒り
嫉妬 落ち込みなどの煩悩を抑えようと
我々は常にもうすでに頑張ってはいる
問題は失敗するんです
人類の歴史の中で盗むことなくなった日はありません
人を殺すことはなくなった日はありません
喧嘩しない日はないんです
では人間だらしないんですかね
そうではないんです みんな頑張ってます
真面目に生きてみようと
これ 宗教は関係ないんですよ
宗教がなくても 人間が真面目に生きてみようと頑張ってますよ
別に宗教のおかげじゃないんです
問題はそれじゃないんですよ
日本人一人も盗み強盗をやりたくないでしょ
やりたくないんだけど
強盗起こるでしょうね
女性を犯したくないでしょ
でもやっちゃいます そこが問題なんです
それがこの裏の心の土台の状況なんです
それ誰も直さないんです
それにブッダ以外誰もアクセスしてないんです
キリスト教も怒りは良くないとかね
もう愛することがとても大事なんですよと言っているんだけど
これ我々知ってる感情なんです
欲張ってはなりませんよとかね
ヒンドゥー教でも同じことを言ってますよ
これは知ってる感情で
我々知らない この基礎のレベルのところは誰もアクセスしてないんです
しかし 成功しません 繊細衝動
衝動をチェックする ですから
お釈迦様が自己診断として
このこの繊細衝動のところにチェックを入れる入れるようにちょっと工夫しているんです
モラリストになったり
無理をしたりする必要はありません
負けて諦める必要もありません
自己診断として繊細衝動をチェックするんです
これカーラム経典でそういうふうに教えているんです
カーラム経典はそのやり方を教えているのです
経典を読むことを推薦します
誰の解説よりも明晰でわかりやすいんです
これから私はちょこっと省略して説明しますけど
無茶難しいと勘違いするかもしれません
だからお釈迦様が口で語った
その口調で経典が出来上がっているんです
だから日本訳でよろしいんです
そのまま過去のごとく私は聞きました
その時 お釈迦様が祇園精舎に住んでおられる時とか
いえ ケーサプッティアの村で旅に出た
その時カーラム 人々が来てこう言またという経典がありますよ
そのまま読んでみてください
びっくりします ものすごくわかりやすいんです
しかし 人間に理解できないほど難しいこと
何の気付かずに教えているんです
あの話実はもう絶対誰にも真似できません
だから私はお釈迦様に対してずいぶん失礼なことをしますよ
省略して説明しますと
これからやりますけど
これでかえってややこしくて難しくなるんです
だから今日の話を聞いても
皆様方は必ずカラーの経典を日本語訳で読んでみてください
日本語訳の方がいいと思います
英訳はちょっと英語のレベルが
なんか英語ちょっと経典の喋り方すごいレベル高いんだから
英語では普通の英語は使えなくなっちゃうんですね
ちょっと難しくなるんです
はい 基本衝動をチェックする
基本症状は貪瞋痴ですね
ミスです それだけチェックするんです
何々やるなかれはいいんです
繊細感情がからその一つ表面に現れたら
それをチェックする 繊細感情からその一つ表面に現れたら
それをチェックする それそんな難しくないんですよ
あの 3つも同時に現れません
波と同じ 波は 1個ずつでしょ
波 2つ同時に現れることないんです
で 欲が現れたり 怒りが現れたり
あるいは無知が現れたりですから
で 例を出します 欲が起きたらチェック
例えば心の中で欲が生まれてくる
あ 欲が生まれたとチェックするんです
次にこう考えるんです
欲に支配されると 人は窃盗
盗み 邪淫 嘘 二枚舌 争語
無駄話 異常欲 異常怒り
邪見という悪行為をやむを得ず犯す
でチェックする 邪見という悪行為をやむを得ず犯すんですね
だから人間のことを親切に見ているんです
あの人は殺生しているんだから
なんて悪い人間かっていうのは仏教ではないんです
あの人はもう邪なみだらな行為ばっかりして
もうとんでもない 出てもう付き合いたくないとかね
これ人を差別して追い出したりするのは
これは意味がないんです
みんなやむを得ずやってるんです
本当はやりたくないんです
やっちゃうんです だからこれはもう究極な
この慈しみのアプローチなんです
人は良いわけでも悪いわけでもなくて
みんななんかかわいそうでハメられてるんだと
欲の感情が出たら まあどうしようもないよと
どうしようもない もう麻薬中毒みたいにもうやっちゃいます
だからそこをチェックする
あ 今怒りが出て 今欲が出てくる
この欲が出てくると 世の中ではみんなこの十悪を犯しますよと
やってはいけない行為は 10種類です
これは十悪というんです
今  10種類も書きました
簡単 そんな難しいたくさんないんです
で これは真空のコントロールですけどね
ああ なるほど はい チェック
それだけ 今 私の心に欲が出てきた
この欲と欲が出てくると
心を支配すると 世の中の人間はやむを得ず殺生もする
強盗もするんだよと なるほど
といってチェック入れるだけで心が守られます
ただそれだけ 何の無理もする必要ないんです
悪行為をしないと頑張る前に衝動をチェックするとそれが消えるんです
あー大変だ 大変だ 私は嘘をつかないように必死で頑張っているんだ
頑張らなくていいんです
そんなのは 私は不倫しないようにものすごい頑張ってますけど
やっぱり時々失敗します
こんな頑張らなくてもいいんです
良い人間になるために
方法ありますよ 自己診断
ただチェック入れるんです
今 欲が出た はい これから私はおかしいことを考える
おかしいことをするだろう
チェック入れちゃうと消えます
自ら悪行為をする意欲が消えるんです
あの 自ら意欲が消えるんです
自動的にあの悪いことしちゃいなと思ってたのに
まあいいやと自動的にこの気持ちが消えてしまいます
あの人にああ言われて
もうもう我慢できない
もうカッとなった ああ
これ怒りだ 怒りということは
これから人に喧嘩したり
殴ったり殺したりすることでしょうね
ああ なるほどと思っただけで怒りは消えて
あの人をぶん殴りたいという意欲も消えてるんです
これで自分が守られているんです
すごい簡単な方法です
しかし これが超越した方法でもあります
同じく怒りも無知もチェックする
今 欲の例出しましたね
それから怒りが出たらまた同じチェックを入れる
無知が出たら同じチェックを入れる
皆様わからないのは無知って何かということをね
このわけもわからないことをもう妄想してるでしょ
妄想ばっかりして もう落ち込んじゃって
もう あの時は無知なんですね
何考えてるか自分でもわからない
その時は無知の衝動 時々貪瞋痴が表に出ないことがあります
時々欲もなく 怒りもなく
無知もない場合もあります
それは不貪不瞋不痴というんですね
不を入れてるだけ 例えば欲が現れてきたらチェックすると欲が消える
あの状態は不貪なんです
別に聖者になったわけじゃなくて
欲が消えただけです これで十分です
この欲がない状態もチェックする
怒りがない状態もチェックする
今はまあ怒りがないね
今楽しい 今ニコニコしている
だからまあ人と喧嘩はしないでしょう
盗んだりはしないでしょう
というふうにチェックする
その時は十悪はしないのです
ああ 今は怒りがないんだから
殺生もしないし 盗みもしない
十悪もしない 今欲がないんだから
殺生などの十悪もしない状態
で 今いるとチェック入れる
それから次 行為と結果のチェックっていうものがあるんです
殺生などで人は不幸になること
理性のある人の批判を受けることを
観察して 貪瞋痴は人の不幸の苦しみのために現れるのだと理解する
で 項目ごとにあります
長いリストですよ 私は省略しただけで
経典では長いリストそのままあります
省略しないで すごく読みやすいし
感動的に読めます で 私もあれを読むたびになんとなくすごい感動しますね
何回読んでいるかわからないんですよ
昨日も読みました 英語ですらっと見て
英語よりは原文の方がかっこいいなと思って
パーリ語で読んで やっぱりサイズを作るよりはそちらに惹かれます
それぐらいすごい 話術は
お釈迦様がね すごいんです
はい それでこういうやり方なんですね
私には今 欲が出ました
欲が心を支配すると 人は自分じゃなくて
自分だけじゃなくて 人は殺生する
盗む 邪な行為をする うんうん
で 殺生やら邪な行為やら
これは世間が批判するんですよと
理性のある人々はこれ情けないと言うんですよと
それでそういうことをやっちゃえば不幸になるんだよと
面白いでしょう 例えば今
私の話から見ると 人はやむをえずやってるんだからしょうがないでしょう
例えば グーッと怒りがこみ上げてきたら
つい人を殺しちゃいます
もう管理できなくなっているんです
やめることをできればやめていたはずなんです
だからしょうがないよとは終わりませんね
世間であなたは人殺しや
これからあなたは裁判を受けて処刑になるんだよと
これで家族まで不幸になるんです
大変です それをチェックしてください
感情的で罪を犯すのは簡単ですけど
それからの結果は大変ですと
それで人の心に欲と怒りと無知が現れるのは
人々の不幸のため 人々をどん底のどん底
不幸のどん底に陥れるためなんです
えらいやばいんです そういうふうにチェック入れる
これがとってもやばいことだよと
原発と同じだよと 貪瞋痴は
どこまで破壊するかわかりませんねとか
チェック入れるだけ 同じく布団婦人不痴のこともチェックするんです
布団婦人不痴になったら
何の悪いこともしない
普通に生きている 普通に仕事をして
料理を作って 子供たちと食べて
もう休みの日に遊びに行って
買い物もして お風呂にも入って
普通に生きている しかし
何の悪いこともしない
誰も批判しません 幸福にもなる
なるほど 貪瞋痴消えたったら
人間というのは幸福になるもんだなぁとチェック入れる
不貪不瞋不痴は幸福のために現れるのだと理解する
自己診断後治療する はい
これでこの人は例えば2
3週間チェック入れたら発見しますよ
あら 私の心から出てくるは出てくるは
欲が出てくるは 怒りが出てくるは
無知が出てくる また欲が出てくる
また怒りが出てくる これやばいもんだなと
なんだこりゃと 時々欲がないわ
時々怒りもないわ 時々無知もないんだけど
また欲があったり また怒りがあったり
もうハチャメチャなんですよ
それで自分の心を感じるんですよ
なんか自分のものじゃなくて
なんか変な組織で なんか変な臭い
汚い組織で もう汚くて臭くて
貪瞋痴で出るわ出るわ出るわ
きりがなく そこに治療するんです
殺生しないように頑張るではないんです
嘘をつかないように無理に頑張るではなくて
この基本的な心に指示するんです
方法があります 次に慈悲喜捨を実践するんです
これは在家のリストです
出家のリストははじめ出しました
罪刑には慈悲喜捨を実践しなさいと
なぜかというと 罪刑が起こる罪はほとんど生命との関係なんですよ
例えばこちら木がありますとしましょう
外を出たら木があります
あの木をちょっと足で蹴ってみてください
あれ 罪ですかね 罪には何でもないんです
そこは あれは木ではなくて
人間だったらどうなるんですかね
大変なことになるでしょ
じゃあ人間ではなくて
人の犬だったらどうですかね
大変なことになるんです
人の犬を蹴ったと それで警察署に行かなくちゃいけない
弁償しなくちゃいけない
謝らなくちゃいけない
大変なことになります
だから罪っていうのは
この生命との関係なんです
一番大きいのは生命との関係なんです
もう一つ罪があるんだけど
思考 他の罪っていうのは
例えば盗んだとする あれは人のものを盗むことでしょ
まあ休みの日 田舎に行って
ちょっと森に入る 森に入ったら何かキノコを見つかるんです
それで取るでしょ 盗んだことになる？ならない
もしその森が そのセクションが個人財産だったらどうなるんですかね
これ大きな問題です あの森は個人財産で
その持ち主の人がそのキノコを取って売っているみたい
それ取ったら盗みなんです
個人のものじゃなくて
まあ国の森で 公の森に行ったところで
キノコを見つけたら誰も文句言いません
あれは盗んだことではありませんね
だから同じキノコを取っても
生命が関わると罪になるんです
面白いでしょう ぶん殴ったら罪じゃないんです
ぶん殴られた側が生き物だったら罪です
硬い石の壁をぶん殴っても罪じゃないんです
思い存分ぶん殴ってください
頭ではいいんです 硬い石を見つけて
罪にはなりません 頭が壊れますけど
そういうわけで お釈迦様が慈悲喜捨の慈悲の瞑想を推薦します
四方八方の無量の生命に対して
慈悲喜捨を実践する これはじわじわと実践して
四方八方の一切の生命のことを慈しみで感じる
自分と同じく感じてしまうところまで実践するんです
念じるんです 幸せでありますように
幸せでありますようにと念じると
何か心の何か 何といいますか
闇があって 闇というか
何か膜があって これ 破れるんです
破れて 自分とはいるのかいと
みんな同じ一緒やと 海みたいに感じるんですよ
生命って言ったら海の水みたいなもんやと
みんな同じでしょ と感じた時点で慈悲の瞑想は完了です
そこで自我が破れているんです
あの基本的な病気 我こそ偉いということはもうないんです
消えちゃったんです それは終わりですよ
一切の次元 制限 バイアスを破った自由自在の心が獲得する
想像できない心が現れます
何のバイアスもない 何の制限もない
何の次元もない すべて破れて
何か空気のような 宇宙空間のような心が現れてくるんです
そこは自由の心というんです
慈悲の実践で心が拡大して
自我の檻を破って自由自在になるんです
安らぎは現実的 一 もし死後の世界があるならば
善行為になる 結果が善悪行為になる
善悪行為に結果があるならば
自分は心配する必要は全くないと現実的に安らぎを感じる
このカーラーマさんたちがすごい疑い深い
どんな宗教も信じたくなかったんです
宗教家が言っていることは互い違いだから
こいつら誰も信頼できませんよと
それでお釈迦様はこういうふうに語るんです
善行為 悪行為に結果があると言っているでしょう
もしそれが本当なら まあ構へん
私は気にしない だって私は全然悪いことしてないんだから
私に悪いことできんだから
私は安心です その宗教に悔い必要はない
自分が自由 どこかの宗教の信仰をしなくちゃとか
そんな義理がないんです
二 死後の世界はないと推測しても
自分は今罪のない生き方をしているので安らぎを感じる
よく疑問がありますね
死後の世界あるないとかね
日本でも死後はないやと
死んじゃったら灰になるだけやという人もいるし
死後は天国に行きますよと思っている人もいるし
そんなのはどうでもいいんです
あってもなくても 今 自分の心は宇宙空間のように広げている
何の罪も起きません それだけで十分幸せなんです
それその安らぎを感じる
3番目の安らぎ 人は行為をするとき
悪を犯す しかし 私に悪意さえも生まれないのだと安らぎを感じる
これも一つの宗教的な言葉なの
私もこれ言いますよ 人間が何やっても罪になりますよと
だって貪瞋痴でやってるでしょうに
これは本当は仏教の言葉よりも他の宗教の言葉なんですけど
何かやったら罪になるんだから
もう大変だ 大変だと もう緊張しててしょうがないんですよ
この人は別にリラックスしているんです
私は別に悪意さえも生まれないんだから
この問題から解放されてますよと
4番目の安らぎ 人の行為は悪にならないという教えが正しいのだとしても
ある宗教はそう言うんですよ
例えば ヘビがカエルを呑む
丸のみにするでしょ ヘビは殺生したのかと
ヘビはカエルやらネズミやら
生きたままで丸のみしなきゃ生きていられないんですね
だからヘビは別に食べてるだけで
殺生するっていうことはないだろうと
同じく人間が魚を取ったり
豚を殺ったり 鶏を殺して食べたり
それは人間が生きるためにやっているんだって
あえてわざわざと殺生とは言えないだろうという
いくつも言う人もいるんです
で 私のページのインターネットにもありましたけどね
戦争が起きたら やっぱり政府が軍事サービスに呼ばれたら行って人を殺さなくちゃあかんでしょうにと
それは人殺しになるのかいと
自分ではやりたくなくても断らないでしょうにと
政府命令だからとかね
この場合 あんたはどうするのかと私に聞くんです
私はどうすることもしません
私に関係ないしね 私は呼ばれませんし
で そういうふうな考え
世の中にあるんですよ
一見まとめな考えのように見えるでしょ
で レパードやらね もうえっとえっとえっとえっと
ジャガーやらね そういう動物はもう小食動物を食べなくちゃいけない
しょうがないでしょうと
同じく人間も同じだと
だったら 金がない人は包丁を持ってコンビニに行くのは何が悪いんですかね
なんでそれだけ悪いと言うんですかね
だってその人は金がないでしょう
仕事もないでしょう だから店で包丁を買うか万引きするかわかりませんだけど
して コンビニに行って包丁を見せて金出せと
それも悪くないと思いますよ
インドでははっきりそれも悪くないと言った宗教があったんです
はい もしそれが正しければどうしますかね
で この人はまあ大丈夫です
私は初めから悪を起こさないんですから
私は安らぎますよと 悪にならないんだから強盗します
悪にならないんだから人を殺します
悪にならないんだから不倫しますとかね
そんなくだらないことを私はやりませんよと
悪になってもならなくても
どうでもいいんだ 私は悪をしないんだと
このように何があっても壊れない安らぎに達します
これが自己診断する方法です
しかし レベルがかなり高いんです
俗世間でやるものとはずいぶん違います
仏教は根本的に最終的に解決する
曖昧はなし 完治する方法を教えるんです
だから 日常生活の中で会社の同僚とうまくいかないとかね
奥さんとうまくいってないとかね
そういうところでどうやってチェックすればいいかという
そういうレベルではないんです
他人に頼らないチェックリスト
この経典は自分で判断して
自分の生き方を自分でチェックする方法を教えているのです
で 人のリストではないので
これは心理学的なリストです
ブッダが ブッダこそが心理学者なんです
ですから これは完全なリストで
これでチェックすると自分でチェックするんだから
誰にも頼る必要はないし
誰にも支配されません
自分の心は自分を騙すのは
普通ですが この問題はこの方法で治ります
普段我々は自分を騙しています
これで治ります 人に無理を決して勧めていないが
完全無欠の精神に達することになるんです
無理をさせてないんですよ
しかし 中途半端でもないんです
しっかり人は成長します
はい これで今日のお話は終了です
えーと まああの この自己診断チェックリストとはパッチウェックかなということなんです
ずっとそれで言ってるんです
パッチワークかな 反省ということ
見てみる あ 怒りだ これはと見てみる
そこはパッチワーク だから初めはパッチワークかなという言葉から始めたんです
はい どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます
今日はすみません 会場の時間の関係で質疑応答は割愛させていただきたいと思います
最後に皆さんで回向の文を唱えて終了したいと思いますので
合掌なさってください
回向の文 仏法僧の三宝に来拝帰依し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サンビーティーワンジャントゥ サッバローゴ ウィナッサトゥ マテー バワット アンタラー ヨウサキ ディガー
ユコー バワ バウトゥ サッバ マングラナンダ カントゥ サッバ デワタ サッバ ブッダヌ バーウェナ サッ
バ ダンマ アヌバーウェナ サッバ サンガ アンバーウェナ サダ サッティー バワントゥ テアビ ワダナ シーリ
ス セー ニッチャン ワッダ パチャイノ チャッパロー ダンマ ワッダンティ アーユワンノ スカンバラモン
はい ありがとうございます
サードゥサードゥサードゥ